I saw in YouTube drama news all day
submit look as I love them and I want to
be in on it but I also want to stay out
because I'm supposed to be I'm trying to
hold myself to a higher standard but I
love hearing about the Jews yeah you're
not hearing about it you don't want to
add anything you just want to be like
out I also do want to add with sometimes
just myself back so you're just gonna be
the one saying try to be professional
let's do it
alright so this was submitted by I like
like here Micah I like a love JK I like
a love Jake Oh like I love Jake hey you
know like like a that one like you are
[ __ ] everyone's English English
[ __ ] up it's an urban dictionary
okuni yeah so a youtubers district
targeted Asian men has been taken down
after violating YouTube a speech
policies what oh I think I'm who is oh
it's a girl I would love to hear your
opinion on this yeah I was showing him
last night all this [ __ ] I was like oh
is it that one white girl that she
thinks she's black and then she faked
[ __ ] the rice cone yeah she's so bad no
but she ought to all Asian dude it's for
him but she's talking [ __ ] it's really
rude yeah he's gotta go through his bra
at the broad response we're so bad she's
that guy's like a [ __ ] his ass oh I know
but like I hear her talk and I think she
has like I feel like mentally she's just
maybe she's a little slow when she talks
for sure an issue stutters a lot like
and she doesn't realize that she she
looks dumb when she's got her I don't
know cuz if you take off the oxide so I
was just horrified
I like her that was meant to be just for
that racism was just for him did not
everybody else yeah calm it when I call
him a ching chong
that's just what that's just rice rice
gum yeah okay
I'm racist but only at you that's that's
the funniest thing ever when I called
him to check the other day I didn't mean
all Chinese just one Chinese it doesn't
work like that I have a lot of video
clips Chang Chong Chong yeah it's
actually kind of catchy
it is really catchy you know what's more
offensive though if she can't be on beat
she's offending music like why are
people so focused on the words we should
can't even [ __ ] ride the beat it's
it's it's so sad
alright so the person we're talking
about her name is Victoria Waldrip aka
whoa Vicki I don't know who this is
alright news to me according to famous
birthday she's 17 years old so damn man
she look but I would love to see this
girl get into Internet beef with the go
down just knock each other out I do
something I think the cat's outside go
up yeah she's a little more legitimized
more like streets yeah her songs are
actually like way better compared to her
so write them he uploaded a video
roasting but wove icky but it was in
response to her talking about him which
it's just a [ __ ] trail of responses
back and forth of roasting each other
but the most recent one though why can't
they just shoot each other
like the good old days I think that's my
friend right now everything's this
tracks their diss tracks not even real
disses though yeah I want to hear a real
battle rap I [ __ ] your [ __ ] that type
of [ __ ] that movie I mean you got
there's gangsta rap but then there's
also even even in that lyrical battle
rap world you know like the whole baby
said these two do it on a on was it VT
or MTV it was called the one that gin
was on Fridays yeah
fighting yes even at that time it was
censored but it was like it was a battle
yeah I don't know what the [ __ ] this is
now it's just I don't understand maybe
it's like playground like playground
sandbox disses it is ya know a lot of us
genuinely fake like let's just read this
each other for views yeah this is faith
man is that anything real outside of
Turkey just shoot each other for the
booze breaking okay okay so I'm gonna
show you guys a quick clip of rice gums
video roasting her okay but I think it's
worth it to go see the whole video just
I found it pretty funny you roast it
pretty well
dad girl dude oh my god I like Cal rice
gum always does it in his bedroom and
anyways what what she thinks she's black
that's my thing okay enough is enough
first he thinks she's black now she
thinks she can sing so she claims that
she's 25% black or according to her
ancestry.com
because her mom also kept saying like
you're not like stop that [ __ ] like and
she's like did hurt her ancestry thing
and then she's like you see I've been
telling everybody so she went on 23 am
Ian [ __ ] no I said ancestry.com oh no
don't go there cuz it's it's no word
where's she from we're in the u.s. issue
I'm not sure actually I don't I feel
like she's that one white girl that grew
up in an all-black apartment and somehow
she thinks she's black uh I don't think
she grew up around black people from
watching like I think she just is
pretending because I've seen her friends
oh you're not like all right so here's
the clip of her responding to rice gums
you use little kids for clout you
distant like bones that all you can do
your [ __ ] how are you and you in you
dissing little kids like oh and that
she's a little kid songs who a ghost
ride is you'd kind of do a better job
cuz your rap still suck she needs to
blow her nose like this are you you just
trying my life well that's a song No
Oh was even better what why doesn't she
blow her nose Hodgins I try to hold it
at home Wow babe oh babe so I'm gonna
play you guys 11 second clip of her
music video how cute they're all little
yeah look at this kid in the beginning
he was like this plenty of thing okay
here we go
[Music]
damn sure got a lot of pieces it looks
like it's professionally done crew
because she's like looking off camera -
yeah so then those are braces the
gorillas she had me she's like ching
chong ching chong team John [ __ ] that
hella racist did she get it close right
well yeah because she's trying to make
fun of him based on his race races you
have a little bit cuz ain't like you
have a little dick and that his
girlfriend supposedly claimed that she
he has a little dick weird like she it's
like a full-on production but she's got
like the clothes line like all this like
all these people she has access that's
for sure cuz I like I know how to handle
the camera decently but my [ __ ] would be
shaky as [ __ ] yes she had a professional
as music so then that went viral she got
a ton of hate cuz they were all saying
that she was just racist and this is her
I really like how she had a have her
black homie just kind of like validate
her validate her blackness hey guys
what's up so I just want to let you know
if anyone's otama anyway an Asian
community took a bit rice go he was he
was being racist towards me so no that
means it might be racist to yourself if
you took offense and please don't
because it's only it's only to him
nobody else she doesn't apologize and
she's admitting she was being racist but
just to race huh
can I get other parts of the song I'm so
interested now I want to hear a verse I
don't have that I just have a little
template it's really bad it's really
really bad it's like well from the from
the holy food from the hook it seems
like she's just dissing herself because
she sucks ass that's the whole song so
it's like it's hard for me to even take
it things are there verses are there
like 16s on there and stuff I couldn't
listen as fast it was
and they're just little kids that they
like they zoom in like you saw the one
that did this like it's just the
performances what does that mean
everybody knows I don't know understand
comment on one of the videos that Rio
bloated cuz you know how in the headline
we said that you took it down because it
was racist one of the Rio blooded videos
it was a comment saying like why did
that kid wipe his nose I guess running
up there like it's because of all the
coke that they snorted like that's like
a sign like they were smoke this morning
but anyway they look really adorable
right there are little they're so
[ __ ] small they're disproportional
thank you you know when we were 17 and
we were doing videos like that and you
see all these old gangland videos of 16
year old child soldiers our generation
look really different making disc tracks
and doing music videos and stuff like
that this is like so innocent and cute
and like it's like oh look at them
trying to be badasses the MattyB dissing
different world man
Matty V distress yes the dramaalert
reported this and then she ends up
responding to drama alert talking shits
a king star and then will respond to us
yeah was somewhat is so funny this world
created an official whoa Vicki YouTube
account because she was saying that like
oh you're using me for clout or whatever
another that's the same thing yeah and
then King star was like [ __ ] so he he
created a YouTube channel and now it has
two hundred and sixty three thousand
subscribers when hers only had like
40-something subscribers like wait how
can he use her for cloud if she only has
forty thousand subs exactly that was his
point and then he was saying like you
know I can I am way more popular than
you could ever be and I'm gonna prove it
to you and so he created this YouTube
account and then he also said that he's
willing to give her this YouTube account
if she's willing to go on his show and
do a DNA test to prove that you know if
she is really black know why is rice
gonna be even wasting time
a channel with 40,000 she was going
viral oh she was oh so he was just
roasting on that stupid singing yeah
yeah I see yeah he wasn't like cuz I
thought he was doing he did a diss track
but it was just him like roasting it
yeah it's like a roast reaction that's
the YouTube drama I think um it's really
really funny that today the stupid [ __ ]
that you do it doesn't disappear it's a
we did a lot of [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] we
were like 12 or whatever right and all
those things aren't really on line so
I'm like yeah alright there's but when
she grows up is still there after she
gets into some serious trouble behind
this [ __ ] is like okay I'm not black
yeah the white lady she was like the
president of the she held a high
position in the n-double-a-cp
yeah she was like pretending to be black
I wasn't mad at her though she was
helping like that's true she had a very
positive outlook yeah well I was stupid
but to go as far as joining a committee
and helping out the cause she was
touched in the head yeah but she was
helping that's pretty funny though
thanks for watching guys and those are
our thoughts what are your thoughts
don't forget to comment below we want to
know what you guys are thinking but
don't write anything that will make it
sad or make us mad because after all
we're just kidding news and we're a very
happy channel for the last video click
up here
[Music]